Paola Es un mar de dudas viene desde
Guatemala con su bebé Hasta la frontera
entre Tijuana y California las
autoridades migratorias le explican que
ahora debe solicitar asilo en la Unión
Americana a través de una aplicación
pues me habían dicho que estaban dejando
pasar
es el fin del título 42 una normativa
amparada en la crisis sanitaria por el
covid 19 que Durante los últimos tres
años ha permitido deportaciones desde la
misma frontera con 10.000 migrantes
cruzando de manera irregular a Estados
Unidos al día durante la última semana
las autoridades temían una oleada de
personas intentando pasar la frontera
Sur pero los datos de México reportaron
una aparente calma el flujo va bajando
el día de hoy cuando menos hasta esta
hora
No hemos tenido confrontaciones ni
situaciones de violencia en la frontera
este bus llevó a los últimos migrantes
deportados bajo el título 42 ahora entró
en vigor una normativa aprobada por el
presidente Joe biden que Beta el asilo a
aquellos migrantes que no hayan
solicitado Primero este auxilio en
algunos de los países que atravesaron
antes de llegar a suelo norteamericano
sabemos que esto es solamente el
comienzo Así que estábamos preparados
nos hemos estado preparando para lo que
sigo diciendo lo desconocido
organizaciones en defensa de los
derechos humanos han criticado esta ley
de la administración biden y la tildan
de ser incluso más estricta a la
implementada por el expresidente Donald
Trump